[Music]
man i'm excited about this dana white
story and damn brazilian too
hope you bring some high [__] with
him
[Music]
so
[Applause]
you spend more time out here
and i'm mike tyson baby
and i'm dana white
and we having some fun let's get into it
so listen dana what's going on epidemic
slowing [__] down
what's happening man
it didn't slow me down we're doing we're
killing it right now i have been through
the whole thing but uh you know it's a
pain in the ass but other than that
our business is doing just fine thank
you brother
[Music]
i think he cares about me
you need to care
he goes i called him up and i said dude
i don't want you to do this [__]
fight man this this is this is [__]
crazy i'll get you i'll get you a job
you know on tv i'll get you a tv show
you make some money
so i put him on shark week so he's like
wait a minute you care about me
[__]
tell me not to fight you put me on a
[__] shortly
yeah you really care about me
i said to
so so the day that he had to jump in and
do the shark thing
i guess he was [__] going crazy he
was pissed off and the whole film crew
was terrified everybody was scared and
[__] he was like he had to dive in the
water and swim with him really well on
it though he looked like nothing you
look like you're gonna find sharks tv
magic yeah
and he goes flying and then the next guy
comes comes up to me and i
i like palm his face as hard as i can
and then they're like oh my god this
this guy was you know is
crazy let's get the [__] out of here
like they've squared up to me for a
minute
and then they ran off like a little
[__] i see over on the dance floor and
we're like
shorts and flip-flops and barely getting
in because we we had friends at the door
and i'm like [__] dude that's that's
mike tyson
and my buddy tim's like what
i'm like dude that's mike right over
there like [__] look over there and
jace is like no way i'm like dude i'm
going over there and you're with like
huge
guys
that look like the guys that you don't
want to bump into when you're ready to
pass
those are the bounces of the club
no i knew all the bouncers at the club i
didn't recognize any of these guys
they're they're all just stacked in this
table
and i'm like i'm like dude i'm going
over there [__] this i
would never like go up and say hi to
like any celebrity or anything like that
i was like dude i'm gonna i [__] have
to go up and say i don't
introduce myself to mike let's just say
he's awesome or whatever
so they're like don't [__] go over
there you're gonna get your ass kicked
and these are two of my toughest friends
i was like i don't [__] care that'd
be a good story so i walked down the
dance they're like i'm not going with
you you're on your own
and
i went down there
and uh and i tapped you on your triceps
i was like hey mike just you know just
want to say i'm a huge fan
and and you know you're [__] awesome
and you started talking to me for like
five minutes you gave me a hug then my
buddies came down
and you were talking to them you're
talking to all of us for five minutes
i'm like dude you're
[__] [__] you know awesome and i was
going through like
some weird
boxing [__]
well even ecstasy
and then and then you were like
uh i was like dude thanks so much for
the time i really appreciate it
and
you shook i was like dude i [__] love
you you shook my hand and you pulled me
in and you go i love you too brother
and then uh
and then you [__] were like super
super [__] rad made my whole life
[Music]